mark barrel lines book urges us not to
trust or believe anyone under 30 because
they're dangerously under informed about
what matters in American culture
politics and ideas what we're going to
do is ask him a bunch of questions from
the home version of are you smarter than
a 5th grader and see how the the man
over thirty fairs and kids kids
questions mark first question for you is
from first grade math there are nine
marbles in a bag five are blue the rest
are yellow how many are yellow for that
is correct second grade science your
part way there which was invented first
the telephone or the radio which was
invented for a second grade math the
telephone that's right do you remember
the year of the telephone 1880s yeah i
think it was eighteen seventy six at the
some exposition yeah yeah third grade
english for the professor of english the
right side of a boat is called what
starboard that's correct oh yeah and you
know what the word aving gave you some
choices you didn't even need that fourth
grade social studies what is the name of
the medieval castle of medieval
cathedral in Paris France let's see
there there are a few there's Santa
Steph what is no dragon of the medieval
cathedral oh hello in here it gives you
three answers no true dom the Louvre or
Versailles so they made it easy for it
no trade on all right fifth grade art
who painted Bible scenes on the ceiling
of the Sistine Chapel nika longish
that's right all right well you're 5 45
and here's for the million-dollar
question okay what newspaper editor
wrote go west young man
and grow up with the country horace
greeley he was also candidate for
president in 1876 okay you need less
shore but you you got it right so that
was a clean sweep you are indeed smarter
than a 5th grade boy why this would be
posted on the web all right well I've
never seen that show but it was very
entertaining and what lion Isis
knowledge in a way that is this is what
we need not not getting the right
answers but recognizing that getting the
right answers is important getting the
wrong answers and then going going and
fixing but what is the attraction of
that format in that show are you smarter
than a 5th grader is it seeing adults
that I think he's humiliated by by the
kid I think certainly that's part of it
that's part of it but it's also
interesting because we all we all have
secret fears of big ones some of us not
so secret a healthy thing yes I think so
mark barrel I thank you very much good
thank you book okay
you